alter ist schon hart an der grenze
das ist klar etwas grafenegg willkommen
waren ein video ja leute ich weiß in
letzter zeit ging es ziemlich oft um
youtube-videos instagram bilder oder
sonst was
und irgendwie muss ich tag kurz mal
drauf anknüpfen weil ich dieses video
auch in planung hatte weil ich ziemlich
interessant finde unter einfach mal du
hast brechen wollte mit seinen partnern
von leute und feierte bestimmt schon am
titel gelesen es geht heute um die meist
geretteten instagram problem die
meistgehassten gehefteten alter was
neues um die meistgehassten instagram
bilder auch ganz instagram darum geht's
ja ich hab ich das nämlich ein bisschen
schlau gemacht und habe mir so das ein
oder andere profil angeschaut und mir
wirklich so die drei krassesten
herausgesucht wir schon fest jetzt
einfach mal zusammen an und analysieren
was ein bisschen ob das wirklich
gerechtfertig ist dass man dieses profil
hätten muss weil halt der content ist
oder ob einfach unsere oberflächliche
gesellschaft der grund dafür ist das
habe ich sehr streng sagte ich will gar
nicht anknabbern lassen nach oben dafür
noch ein paar davon
und es hat auf jeden fall meine
kommentare ob ihr auch einen intern
profil kennt was wirklich krass geld
wird dann schickt mir ist auf jeden fall
ich schaue mir das mal an
und vielleicht gibt es da auch ein paar
jetzt folgen und zwar fangen mit dem
ersten profil an ein mal die regie bitte
einbinden
fehler von der sie das kann dann muss
euch jetzt ein kleiner fehler und
verlaufen sein es kann ich leider nicht
annehmen
ich will nicht und ich weiß warum musste
so kommen wir zu den ersten profil und
zwar nennt sich das hört sich spanisch
oder portugiesisch an tieren auf 2,9
millionen vorne war und wirklich so auf
jedem bild auch so die 150000 leicht
oder 100000 live aber halt auch wirklich
eine menge kommentare die ich nicht
verstehe weil sie wirklich sehr sehr
auch beleidigt und ich denke du es doch
ein schönes foto zum beispiel dieses
bild 440.000 leicht und 2000 oder 3000
kommentare und davon sind echt sehr
viele negativ und das ganze liegt wohl
daran weil sie irgendwie mal von vorn
gesungen hat oder halt nachgestellt hat
wieso typ ist musical ja ich glaube das
war diese sketchen die auszeit oder so
also ich habe das ein bisschen
recherchiert und das war irgendwie ein
bisschen zu weit unter der gürtellinie
warum auch immer und deswegen jetzt
einfach an der und beleidigt wohl japans
worte fakt ist warum bist du als
übersetzt sich eine hose was es wird
hier oder gleiche story the man they
take that s what the [ __ ] the police
marotten tisch also die soll heiß baden
gehen weil ihre unterhose nach rotteten
fischers alter ist sie absolut nicht was
ist wenn das foto sieht doch mega gut
aus volle hütte und also der kommentare
zu recht kann ich hab auch noch etwas
weiter geschaut und da gibt es noch ein
video was auch eine millionen user hat
auf instagram schauen wir mal kurz rein
[Musik]
ich finds jetzt nicht schlimm aber ist
logisch das gibt anlass zum helden und
irgendwie ist das verhältnis zu viel ihr
könnt euch ja selber mal anschauen aber
andauernd stehen da irgendwelche
negativen kommentare ok ich muss aber
dazu sagen unter dem video stehen auch
viele positive kommentare auf jeden fall
aber irgendwie auch viele nicht
verärgert war das erste profis arbeite
ich habe auch ein paar andere ausgesucht
und zwar das zweite ziemlich echt mega
kraft vielleicht habe davon gehört in
irgendwelche nachrichten oder sonst und
zwar ist das der liebe der liebe ist auf
jeden fall irgendwann typ aus australien
und er nennt sich candy shop menschen
sein erfolg sonst hätte ich meinen dass
muss man ganz offen sagen erst 706.000
voller war ist seit fotos von
irgendwelchen geilen autos
beziehungsweise hauptsächlich
irgendwelchen freizügigen die in hoher
anzahl um ihn herum stehen und
irgendwelche sexuellen posen einnehmen
sobald ein etwas ganz dass man sowas
instagram posten kann die zeit einfach
komplett nackt das kann ich gar nicht in
meinem video einbauen
ich habe jetzt mal zwei bilder
herausgesucht die vielleicht ein
bisschen widerspiegeln was eröffnet ich
weiß nicht ob ich die im nachhinein ein
bisschen tendiere auf jeden fall zum
beispiel dass hier
er liegt auf dem bett und zwei frauen
schlagen sich gegenseitig die eines
gefesselt und die andere schlägt die
alters ist schon hart an der grenze
das ist klar als an die ganzen kleinen
not kleinen jungs das ist auf jeden fall
hier für euch da könnte auf jeden fall
mal vorbei schauen dass wir euch
gefallen das kann schon sicher im alltag
ziemlich richtig rad oder zum beispiel
dieses bild er geht damit zwei frauen
ich schäme mich schon das auszusprechen
an einer leine spazieren also die frauen
werden halt praktisch als seine runde
dargestellt vor einem lamborghini also
da kann ich nur sagen dass das profil
schreibt ihm die scheiße ist und feiere
ich absolut nicht sowieso dann kommen
auch schon zum letzten von 24 darf
princess airprint ist meckern postete er
auch fotos von ihrem hintern wie sie zb
word kann ich einmal kurz zeigen
[Musik]
auf jeden fall super gut ich kann so was
ganz einschätzen ob das jetzt gutes oder
nicht und ich weiß gar nicht warum sie
so krass gerettet wird aber die merken
wird gehänselt wenn man hier und heute
an sieht man dass viele der letzten
fotos glass touren mit jesus bilder
wurden die kommentare aufgestellt wenn
man jetzt die jetzigen fotos anschaut
dann kann man sehen auch das beste sich
auf jeden fall viele schreiber auch
positive sachen hauptsächlich jungs oder
männer immer uns dieses bild mal
anschauen
ich habe irgendwie herausgefunden die
hat sich irgendwie ihre brüste abnehmen
lassen oder so warum auch immer
das kann ja auch zum teil was schlimmes
gewesen seien und deswegen wurde sie
halt gerettet weil sie das gepolsterte
hat foto muss ich jetzt glaube ich nicht
einblenden finde ich absolut
schwachsinnig den menschen deswegen zu
helfen
man weiß ja nicht was genau passiert ist
deswegen leute beurteilt niemals
irgendwelchen dessen lebensgeschichte
ihr nicht kennt oder dessen charakter
ähnlich kennt oder vom fass und in
welche die ganze zeit irgendwas von bits
also irgendwie nennt sie alle mit kraft
und was ich gerade noch gefunden habt
zurück zu candy shop menschen unter
diesem bild wo sich halt diese beiden
frauen da schlagen und er da liegt er
hat was genau am national woman's day
hochgeladen das ist so richtig
berechnete provokation
also ich feiere eigentlich so berechnete
provokationen und so wenn man alles
berechnen kann und ganz neue weise was
ankommt aber bei so was dann eventuell
auch nicht jamaika vandrey der meist
gehypten instagram profile die es gerade
gibt wie gesagt mir auf jeden fall noch
mehr hast du ich muss mich jetzt mega
bei allen weil ich es wieder schneien
und und danach geht's zum video preis
liegt auf jeden fall snitil und
instagram folgt mir da gerne
lasst doch nach oben da ist es viel
gefallen hat und mein merchants online
das ist nicht mein match ist meine
klamotten praxis ist aber alles eine
bestattung haut rein wir sehen uns am
freitag oder sonntag 1